reaction all of this donald trump jr you
know i
on the issue of cuomo on covet alone
it was your father that built the
hospitals man the hospitals
changed the ventilation systems so to
allow for covert patients to be there
eighty percent of those hospital beds
were never
used there never was a reason to send
people back to the nursing homes
there were enough beds built by your dad
never mind the vaccine that democratic
governors are having a hard time
distributing that your father got three
of them and left for joe biden
yeah sean uh it's sort of amazing they
don't talk about the hospital
mercy that was also sitting in new york
harbor vacant so that andrew cuomo could
send your grandmother back into a
nursing home
infected or amongst other infected
people that led to the deaths of
thousands of people
that's the insanity of the left today uh
you know honestly
that is probably the bigger scandal
although it seems like perhaps the
democrats are sweeping them
under the rug in lieu now of
the accusations against our groper in
chief as a governor of new york
uh it's sort of amazing because on today
as international women's day
i was beginning to think that the left
don't actually believe
all women i sort of feel like they were
going to give a pass to democrat
congress people the person you mentioned
earlier andrea stewart cousins
last week she actually said well if
another accuser comes out then he should
resign now bear in mind
three had already done it so i guess if
you're a democrat governor
you get that kind of leeway the left is
really busy spending a lot of time
trying to cancel
uh characters cartoons like pepe le pew
when they could be actually trying to
cancel people who are actually
behaving like pepe like times 10
and it happens to be the governor of new
york this kind of stuff is disgusting
sean
it's gone on too long the democrats get
a pass
those passes are a one-way street they
only go towards democrats
if this was a republican in this
situation whether it was the one scandal
both scandals a fraction of those
scandals this thing would have been over
a long time ago
but andrew cuomo gets to get away with
it if you look at the people
who have accused him they're all tied to
the democrat party mechanism in new york
it seems to me how many more are there
sean
how many more are there that are just
afraid to come forward because it would
be damaging
to their career in democrat politics i
understand that
there would be reprisals you think that
people in the cuomo
machine won't go after those people i
can almost guarantee you that there are
a lot more
that are just either afraid to come out
for those reprisals or don't want to do
damage to the democrat party in new york
which is about as corrupted and
ridiculous as it gets
and we're seeing that with our very own
eyes the media made this guy a hero
they made him a deity he was literally
49 or 50 out of 50 states
in terms of performance and yet because
he was willing to talk poorly
about my father they gave him a throne
and a specter
and they let him do his thing it was a
joke
and it was a sham and i think we're
starting to realize that now
we're not hearing we're not hearing i
believe
uh finally some democrats have been
shamed into saying
oh this is serious but we've got to give
due process they didn't give it to you
father they didn't give it
they would never give it to anybody with
the last name trump let's be honest
they didn't give it to brett kavanaugh
let me ask you
throw out a question and i know it's a
hard state
would you ever consider running for
governor of new york
you know that it's an honor that's kind
of mission impossible the answer is
yeah now it's listen i mean i think you
need someone who's a fighter i just have
no interest in that job i think that
would be like the tortures of the damned
uh so you know the answer is no for me
but i'd love to see someone who's
actually willing to fight someone who'd
actually take that on if you look at
what's going on
in the city it's a disgrace the greatest
city in the world
it's like a zombie apocalypse happened
i feel like i'm watching i am legend
when i go to work
uh it's disgraceful and what they did
destroying businesses if kovitt
disappeared tomorrow
sean and you flipped on the switch it
would take probably a decade for new
york to get back to where it was
and it's because of incompetence not
because of anything else and we know
that because we've seen states
like texas and florida be able to behave
competently and not destroy their
economies in the process
all right don jr always good to have you
thank you for being with